la mission surprise va porter sur le
film bien entendu sur vos carrières jean
michel maire at il bosse et on va le
savoir dans un instant s'il n'a pas
bossé pendant la pub pendant toute la
pub on a eu des kits united dans un
instant il montera un groupe avec deux
personnes âgées et fera les yeux d un
drôle ça sauf que j'ai bossé et donc on
va voir on va voir bien sûr si vous
perdez vous désignerez quelqu'un une
personne plutôt hachée pour le faire à
votre place
bien entendu méfiez-vous ceux qui sont
encore là dans le film demi-soeur la
grand mère du personnage de sabrina
salma compare les hommes un autre
quotidien
non mais là n'est pas interrogée à mais
j'adore cette phrase mais alors alors
alors antérieur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces données les aimez vous allez venir
là maintenant pour écrire parce que j'ai
peur quand vous trichez et j'ai regardé
le film j'en ai alors les attend c'est
un des extraits qui ressort vraiment de
vue pour avoir peut-être que c'est pas
ça et je vous des chauffe et si je sorte
de les voir faire un caleçon pour
comparer les hommes à qui vient de dire
très bien vraiment la honte regardez
vous avez gagné non plus pas le train de
s'amuser parce que plus facile à
transporter sa défense s'en sort tarek
et alors tu sais bien les hommes c'est
comme une théière petite tête au ventre
et que toujours en l'air maman ou
confirmés oui je m'étonne que vous avez
connu c'était sa charlotte et moi on se
connaît très très bien le dire on a beau
voyage ensemble oui c'est après qu'ils
se dire mille nantes
on a fait des tournées ensemble là on
les appelle la petite payeur chavanon
mais non tous les hommes que vous avez
connu n'était pas comme ça
non mais je veux bien la question
suivante merci ça pue ça c'est vrai ce
que tu sais pas si vous attaquez
quelqu'un soit en baisse que l'homme
avec qui vous êtes et peut qu être
comparée à cette théière
non non non non non ne riez pas être
très bien parfait il est ça va il emmène
dans la tête
à l'été chéri on passe on passe le
métier du personnage d'alice david dans
la série bref dans la série en pole de
la carrière
attention prof d'histoire photographe de
mode caissière dans un sex shop à la
haye il a voulu mais on va y aller il va
travailler les invités et le film la vie
l'autre 2 je suis ton prof d'histoire
est caissière dans un sex shop et je
vais dire prof d'histoire et alice
caissière dans cette série vous avez
explosé
bref été diffusé tous les jours sur
canal + dans le grand journal va revoir
ensemble un extrait on apprend votre
métier entre autres
c'était le tout premier épisode j'ai
déjà été dans un sex-shop comme ça pour
le but est d'ailleurs charles parents
viennent pour le week end
j'essaye de toujours trouver des trucs
sympas alors oui alors juges tiennent
une fois pas aujourd'hui mais c'est par
exemple
non c'est comme l'histoire du pays
basque moi j'ai prise des mimiques du
cash mais en fait j'avais pas à ces
jeunes parce que j'ai acheté plusieurs
choses on s'en fout mais comme on peut
mais petite info personnes quand vous
payer en carte de crédit c'est le seul
endroit où sur le ticket de caisse
il n'y a absolument rien marquer sauf le
montant à where we et où le ticket d
elle que très remarquée sexy show bien
pourquoi ma petite info que je vous
donne sa mère il a une allure de crédit
circule et vous avez déjà été lancés le
choc
oui ça m'est arrivé non j'adore parce qu
elle elle dit tout sur le mail
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
pour le même reportage et avec maxime
qui n'a pas maxime gainey avec mathis
normaux on est bien sûr avec mathieu
béda yves non ben non non mais jamais
été dans un sex-shop mais très bien fait
ou on les regardait en tout cas l'expert
j'avais repéré cette fille à la soirée
de moddeurs alors j'y suis allé j'avais
fait une blague elle a rigolé que j'ai
eu en effet une deuxième elle n'a pas
rigolé mais elle avait pas compris que
j'avais pas compris
alors ça va je vais demander tu fais pas
dans la vie je suis caissière s'était
pas perdre dans un sex shop se perdre du
coup j'ai plein d'échantillons c'était
très intense et hashomer elle m'a dit je
vais fumer je supporte pas la cigarette
mais je supporte pas la solitude elle
n'a jeté un regard ça m'a troublé et
puis kheiron m'a fait un signe discret
pour m'encourager
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup pour l'instant vous n'avez
qu'un point je rappelle qu'il vous faut
la moyenne pour ne pas faire les united
si vous nous rejoignez un bien entendu
avec trois invités dans quelle émission
de radio charlotte gabris pas rester sur
le film la fée de ski connaît aucune
émission de radio charlotte était-elle
chroniqueuse aux miches aux côtés de
michel drucker comment s'appelait
démission chavez moi s'appelait
l'émission vivement dimanche
c'est cette mission sur votre fiche et
ses passages étroits que michel drucker
il s'embête pas quoi dire là bruxelles
dumas dimanche pas que le gars toutes
les sauces non c'était quoi
l entraîneur va être l invité vous avez
fait un rôle un sketch très drôle dans
le cadre de la promotion de votre
spectacle vous avez fait un petit sketch
avec michel drucker regard des
challenges et un truc a dit tu es
dernière chronique ses moyens d'accord
je te dise franchement c'est un peu nul
c'est même quand même à chier bas donc
tu sais ce que ça veut dire ouais oui
pour mieux la prochaine fois
non il n'y aura pas de prochaine fois tu
as dis là non c'est fini c'est fini
c'est fini tu vois il ya un début une
fin et c'est la fin des longues et je
veux dire après qu'un charlaté monde
s'adore oui on est les deux personnes
qui adorons le plus au monde entier
jamais je vous le dis jamais nous c'est
pareil
rien rien et personne ne dit benhaim
c'est pas toi qui passe mal il a
repoussé de fait l'influencé de francky
a oui je les adorais balle alors là oui
mais c'est les titres ont adoré alors à
we made you et oh allez il n'y a pas le
choix
ban avait pas de choix allez c'est quoi
le film dit trois secondes 1,2 à tarbes
atteinte les bâtards non non non on a le
droit de tricher
quand c'est bien fait c'est bon comme on
s'y attendait pas telara pattaya c'est
lui c'est comme ça à quoi regarder
c'était une blessure de de l'excellent
du meilleur il est au dessus de tout le
monde en gazole embrasse fort franck
gastambide bien sûr mon frère voilà ici
c'est plus que mon frère d'ailleurs et
ya une semaine qui est devenue culte ou
vous mettez une énorme droite affronte
on va la revoir au début être ma meuf
tout allait bien ce qui ferait de pau
puis elle a commencé en avoir marre à
cause de ma passion que je ressemble à
du diesel j'ai alors ça a commencé à
être un peu moins la fête du slip c'est
ta copine quoi même constat qui reste en
amour elle était fière de moi et à
bochum et eysseric se plaît sur la tête
de ma mère un tout jeune de maîtrise
beaucoup trop attaquer et ses regrets
pour des frites comme ça et j'embrasse
fort mon poto franck gastambide c'est
sympa de tourner avec franck gastambide
bas c'est génial c'est génial où il sait
où il va il nous embarque qui nous fait
rire il est discipliné
non j'adore j'adore paraît vraiment
j'aime plus que vous en quelle langue
qui aurait joué sur ça va jouer sur ça
attention lors de l'émission le gros
show spécial pattaya justement sabrina
réalisé un numéro dangereux qui consiste
à jongler avec des ballons se réaliser
des acrobaties ou pas ses nuits avec
jean-michel mère d'un petit indice
jongler avec des balles en feu sont bien
les ballons peu attention si c'est la
mauvaise réponse aux frais légaux
pénalité pour la peau du lycée quand tu
te sens pas très bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
genre sont au vert